super bowl 58 will be hosted right here
in the valley today the nfl announcing
its decision to hold the massive event
right here in february 2024. eight
sports now director chris matthews live
from allegiant with that big
announcement we're all smiling chris
this is good stuff
well good afternoon las vegas a historic
day here in our city of course las vegas
we are inside allegiant stadium and
joined by the man whose name whose
company is on the outside of legion
airlines maury gallagher who is now the
chairman of the host committee for super
bowl 58 what an exciting day and
historic day for las vegas well you
can't underestimate how big of a day
this is many years in the coming we
couldn't be more excited both for having
our name on the stadium but in a
personal note being on the committee
this is going to be great for this town
and i think we're going to we're going
to wow the crowd you know as the
chairman of that host committee you were
mentioning here you only have a couple
years to prepare other cities have more
time but city had this city has the
experience i'll get it done well i don't
think there's any city in the u.s
literally the world that has the
expertise and the ability to do it and i
feel a lot more comfortable as the
chairman of the host committee having
the lvcva it's like your dad standing
behind you you know make sure you don't
get run over
any doubts in your mind that this super
bowl 58 will be the biggest and best
because of the city that's behind it no
no i mean the irony of it is i think we
have more people come to this city for
the super bowl then go to the super bowl
city in historical terms so you put that
together with the people that will come
for the game there aren't many places
that could host that kind of numbers and
do a good job like we'll do well i know
your work starts actually tomorrow right
or maybe today today yeah well you can't
waste a day given the time we have all
right hold that helmet up right there
there it is right there super bowl 58
coming to las vegas along with the man
who's going to chair the committee
that's going to be exciting i'm chris
matthews inside allegion stadium we are
live local now all right